I am a naiyeer I don't really think that
it's the case at all that what we do is
worthy of any significant amount of
criticism because of the absence of
scientific support for a ban on welfare
bans in this country p i reaiiy really
don't think it's the case and then also
public opinion no matter what the
opinion polls say I would I would
question them if they were at all
accurate we wouldn't be here working
well you know it's awesome to see and
these animals look incredibly healthy
they look happy as well and I just sit
here and I wonder you know just in this
day and age it's not right to see that
sort of thing and I think people ask a
question how do you tame a lion to
perform tricks can you assure them that
there is no cruelty involved in that I
can yes lions and tigers
like any other animal they're not
animals that have to be forced into
anything through cruelty that's not the
way any form of training works it's not
the way any decent form of training has
ever works you can train any sort of an
all-weather wild or domestic to perform
actions the the issue that a lot of the
advocates for animal rights have with
what we do is just a purely it's purely
a matter of context no one has it issues
with animals being trained for obedience
whether it's a your own house pets at
home your dogs or cats or animals in
zoos but the second it's labeled
entertainment that's when people have
the issue with it I've got three typical
teenage children and I think my Chum
would have a real problem with going to
see your show with these lions in it
because their view would be well lines
shouldn't be in this scenario they
should be out in the wild so bearing
that in mind if they are typical in the
future there is going to be no demand
for this kind of act anyway well I'm
sorry to say that that's just not the
case in terms of the general public's
opinion if that was the case like I said
already we wouldn't be here working yeah
where are you banned what are you not
allowed to work Thomas well we're
allowed to work pretty much any
there's been no actual band been put in
place yeah okay
and just final question to you
incidentally I believe a swear word
slipped out I haven't I didn't notice it
but viewers at home of noticed it so we
just have to apologize and for your
potty mouth there so forgive that
forgive us for that well I well I didn't
hear you say it my friend but somebody
says you did just in case we're just
covering ourselves and but basically
getting in I mean those beasts at any
stage those magnificent animals could
decide to have you for tea will to have
you for breakfast lunch or tea are all
three and high scary is it in there I've
never been worried working with my
animals I've always respected them what
they are remembered what they are and
taking that into account when working
with them I don't force them into
performing actions they're not
comfortable doing that's not the way I
work with my animals the way I introduce
them to new actions is on a gradual
basis making sure they're comfortable
with it and if I don't feel they're up
to do any particular action on any given
day I won't make them do it yeah okay
okay Thomas and very interesting you'll
get people talking today appreciate your
time in your trouble today and thank you
very much indeed for speaking to us
thank you
Thomas chipper